when's the last time you sat down and
thought is this life that I have the
life that I want
and if it isn't what am I doing each day
to work towards the life I do want as an
idea I talk about in the mind manual
it's called the traffic light Theory we
go around we'd say red Amber or green
how you're feeling today now if I said
that I was Amber every day maybe every
day the similar stress or pressure was I
was facing maybe I just can't get quite
on top of my sleep it allows you and as
that person to learn about why they
might feel a certain way also allows the
people around you to learn what's normal
for them remember sitting there
literally like sobbing away reading it
being like it's going to get better it's
going to get better and thank God it did
it did get better and after eight to ten
weeks
it was like a cloud lifted